steve how's it going nice to
nice to see you nice to see you um i
have to start with a few important
questions
what the hell do you get sean levy as
like
christmas gifts for basically changing
your life giving you these great roles
you know stranger things and now free
guy well sure yeah i
agree so i i have his laundry that i
have to do every week
i have um the car i have to wash his car
i have to wash all the dogs
um uh no i mean there's really nothing i
could do to
he's kind of been a champion of mine for
some unknown reason to me really
um but i think since we started working
together i feel like
i've always just you know enjoyed being
around him
and talking about you know what we do
and um you know really look up to him as
a uh
creative and and uh you know business
man i guess in the industry i think he's
i think he's a very
very unique person in in this industry
where he is
such a beautiful balance of this
business and this creative and it comes
together in such a
an amazing way especially on set too
yeah he's great
i don't know i guess is my answer can't
revamp
do you think that you tweet too much
um me no i no i
i uh yeah my relationship uh
with social media is just slowly falling
away
i don't listen i don't i don't blame you
i i think that anyone who's in the
limelight
uh i don't know how you stay on social
media yeah
yeah just yeah yeah so no i guess
um so one of the things about this movie
is uh ryan
and sean added a number of like funny
bits in post-production
you know stuff that wasn't scripted so
i'm curious for you what was it like
watching the finished film for the first
time
with some of the surprises that maybe
weren't in the script
well um i had
seen a rough cut so i had kind of seen
like the rough
it was more than just the assembly it
was like they had cut the majority i
don't think the full effects the the
i think the special effects and some of
the sequences that i was involved in
that they kind of fleshed out like when
we're going up the stairs and we're
chasing him
that that was pretty you know pretty
incredible to see that um and then
obviously some of the cameos that i
didn't know about were incredible to see
as well
um and you know just like the
you know the beautiful bits of
filmmaking like the sound design or like
you know the color correction of the
whole thing you know
subtle things that you don't necessarily
notice when you're kind of getting into
it on the day to day but then it's the
it's really the thing like the foley
stuff like that really brings it to life
especially when you're sitting in a
cedar and you've got like you know dolby
surround sound
yeah 100 last question for you um i love
learning like surprises
about the filming process things that
maybe people wouldn't have heard about
what do you think might surprise people
to learn about the making of free guy
actually my character was supposed to be
in the bunny suit at one point in the
script
um and that was
switched and i don't remember why
got it mate i was i was going to make a
joke about this but i'll leave it alone
i'll just say
seriously congrats on the movie it's so
so good
um have a great day good luck with the
rest of the interviews
thank you very much appreciate it man